at this time you can placing you under
arrest for your street racing all right
I wasn't racing
a sheriff's deputy is arrested after
allegedly street racing on his new
motorcycle he says he was speeding to
impress the girl on the back of the bike
we're going on a date
it's really bad I don't speed at all it
happened on August 30th in Saint Cloud
Florida about an hour south of Orlando
that evening a Saint Cloud police
officer noticed two motorcycles speed by
his vehicle traveling between 80 and 90
miles per hour in a 45 mile per hour
Zone when the officer put on his Sirens
one of the motorcycles pulled over while
the others sped off
I got one please
body camera video shows the Saint Cloud
officer approached the remaining
motorcyclist later identified as Orange
County Sheriff's deputy Brian espinal
Ting the officer he doesn't know the
other driver before revealing his status
as a deputy
who's that I don't know
we'll look you up
I got you I'm I'm Deputy okay push it
over you
the responding officer can be heard
calling in the situation noting espinal
pulled over
five St Cloud 1065 at Florida 1028
x-ray two seven
mwtx27 should come back to a white BMW
the one that stop is with the female
after that espinal admits he doesn't
have his registration
I don't have my registration on me boss
um
it's at home okay the first responder
can then be overheard explaining what he
witnessed just before pulling Aspen all
over I I'm doing 50. they fly past me
like I'm standing still
splitting Lanes foreign
just traffic
going uh I was doing 50 they flew past
me at least at least 80 90. I was like
standing still when they came past me
were you able to you got a radar no to
be able to Pace them at all no I tried
to catch up to them I couldn't
they tell me who the other guy is
they were talking he says he doesn't
know who he is
and they were both going about the same
speed
[Music]
multiple officers then question espinal
about how fast he was speeding again
asking whether he knows the other driver
espinal explains his side of the story
admitting it quote looks bad
I don't know honestly
going and then
we parked up over here and then that's
going on there oh you got a nice bike
you gotta have a cx-10r I got a s1k
that's
I'm just coming off of my friend's house
and then from Saint Cloud and Park
so what light were you at
no we're right here and then we were
just going
um from
um Hickory yeah they passed me at
Crawford
Zoom
because I was like
that looks bad
the only person
it looks on my part and I understand you
know I we're going on a date night and I
just got the bike not too long ago
sure and
really bad I don't
I don't know espinal again admits he
wanted to impress the woman he was with
and it's
it's
the first time she's on it I just got it
at the dealership you guys can see it's
a brand new 2023. I wanted to test it
out I just finished installing
everything I had like the exhaust and
everything the officers continue to
question espinal about racing but he
maintains he was not planning to run off
from First Responders
you know see how that looks and it
wasn't like that
other pedestrians are the roads somewhat
wet are your driving conditions Reckless
Mouse
Wayne split around the red light
when we came up here
he looked back he saw me I got grabbed
his keys
he looked at me
take off on you guys like I'm not gonna
do that I didn't know who you were man I
don't know who you are you know bikes
take off from us all the time
I understand I'm like this is my first
time ever getting pulled over after that
the group moves the motorcycle off to
the side of the road
you guys want to step over here
you stand right in front of the bike
as espanol stands off to the side a
group of First Responders discussed the
situation
so you have speed a bunch of illegal
Lane changes
remember the articulation of the last
street racing thing that you had yeah
you know
you know we're doing thorough
documentation on driving pattern road
conditions uh you know the amount of
vehicles that are on the road all the
different Lane changes any other traffic
violations that you have
you know that in addition to the well
over the criminal you know the mandatory
criminal appearance on the speed
that's going to lead you to have
Reckless plus the other one plus the
other one they're obviously in a speed
competition that they're doing over
twice the legal you know the twice the
speed limit on the road
so it is what it is he's a deputy we
apply the law evenly
so you're the one that witnessed
everything so okay if we have it we have
it okay okay
so go with that I'll take yep
after that espinal is taken into custody
your boss to me
I turn around
do you have anything on you that's gonna
stick me poke me or hurt me
I'm placing you under arrest for your
street racing all right
wait wait
no no no guys come on
wait I wasn't racing I was not racing
okay I wasn't there this officer
oh my God
okay what do I do
is there anything that's going to save
me poke me or hurt me there's no way
babe
20 years yeah
baby but wow
oh my God
can I speak to the cow
s
his number is here
um
can you give me one second
later he's loaded into the back of a
police truck
do you see that there's nothing on the
floor
see though there's nothing on the
foreign
station and placed in an interview room
all right boss
I just have a seat over there uh you
want me to put the cups around for you
guys
need any water or anything
yeah
espinal now faces charges of reckless
driving and racing on the highway as the
investigation continues he's been placed
on administrative duties only at the
Orange County Sheriff's Office reporting
for long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie